today we're going to be speaking to john
mark hanson who's a professor
in political science at the university
of chicago we are going to talk a little
bit about
uh what would it look like to rig and or
steal an american
presidential election mark it's great to
have you on
thank you it's great to be here so okay
i mean at this point i don't think we
have to rehash all of the claims that
were made between november 4th
and january 6th or january 20th or even
up until today and continue to be made
let's just get into the reality so so
maybe the audience can understand what
would go into this
could could a an american presidential
election which is really
50 state elections could it be rigged
could it be stolen how would it have to
be done if so
well i would say that it's difficult to
the point of impossible
i think many people just don't
understand the scale of the effort that
would be involved to
actually fix a presidential election
you're not talking about
a few hundred votes you're not talking
about a few thousand votes you're
talking about tens
or even hundreds of thousands of votes
uh spread along a number of states
so there are folks who will say well you
know 80 million votes versus 75 million
or whatever you
you don't really need to flip millions
of votes you really need for example in
2016 it was 77 000 votes in three states
in 2020 it was depending on how you
slice it about 100 000 votes
that's very different than millions so
that presumably would make it simpler
uh simpler but not by any means simple
um if you imagine what it would take to
shift
uh a number of votes and and bear in
mind that
you don't know exactly where the problem
is going to be you don't know exactly
what the
margin you need is and you don't know
exactly where it's going to be
so you have to start months in advance
and you have to be thinking in terms of
tens of thousands of votes
and you have to be thinking about how it
is that you would
recruit tens of thousands of people to
participate in this effort
without anybody blowing a whistle on you
okay so let me play devil's advocate
maybe you don't need to recruit tens of
thousands if you can just get
a few tech people who quote control the
voting machines
that might be a simple way and you might
only need five or six people
well that is the case however
um you still have to maintain a
conspiracy of those five or six people
um and one of the things we know is it's
very difficult to maintain conspiracy
so there are many many business frauds
that go awry
or criminal frauds or criminal
activities that go awry because
people feel the need to say something
either because they want to boast about
it
or because they have a guilty conscience
or whatever
so you would have to you would have to
have a great deal of trust in your
confederates
but even beyond that there are lots and
lots and lots of barriers have been
erected to actually manipulating the
vote in that way
there are security measures for the
technology
that's used in voting and vote counting
and moreover there's the knowledge of
the
um there's the knowledge of the people
who are overseeing the voting process
and so if some county comes in all of a
sudden with 10 000 more votes than
they've ever
cast before someone might say boy that
looks kind of fishy
maybe we'll look closer at that there
are
so many different claims that have been
made about
mechanisms for subterfuge some of which
conflict with each other and maybe
i don't know how much we need to
necessarily get into that but just to
talk about a few of the different things
there's
as i mentioned the idea of simply using
hacking skills to change the vote
tallies of a group of voting machines
we heard stories of so-called massive
dumps of ballots coming in in the middle
of the night on vans and and
literally just taking boxes of ballots
out which
presumably in that case the voting
machines aren't being manipulated but
someone's
feeding in a bunch of ballots there's
the idea of having
election workers look at ballots
and then disqualify only some presumably
to help one candidate and hurt the other
all of these are based on different
principles and what to me seems very
difficult would be
that you might end up with one of these
strategies
working against a different one
conflicting the coordination of such
strategies seems extraordinarily
difficult
yeah it's enormously difficult um
take take for instance the idea of a
bunch of ballasts that get dumped
so most states uh most jurisdictions in
fact
allow partisan observers to ballot
counting
and so all of a sudden these ballots
come in and someone might say so where
did they come from
um how do we know that they're authentic
there should be a mark on the ballot um
there should be some kind of record
that the person at the polling place
actually
authorize this person to vote or if it's
an absentee ballot
it should meet the requirements for
absentee ballots which often times
include a signature
they include a valid application all
kinds of things so there are all kinds
of safeguards
to prevent ballots from being submitted
fraudulently and certainly
all kinds of safeguards to make sure
that if there
are frauds that there's a likelihood of
they're being discovered
particularly on a large scale yeah when
it comes to in-person voter fraud
uh the idea of someone i don't even know
sometimes it's not even clear to me
exactly how you would do it you would go
to multiple polling places or show up
and claim to be a variety of different
people i mean
you wouldn't be registered in multiple
places so going to polling places as you
wouldn't wouldn't work i guess you could
show up and say at one polling place you
say you're joe smith and at the next
play you say
you say you're steve johnson and that
type of thing but it seems like
in order to flip 50 000 votes with that
strategy
you need thousands of people making it
incredibly unlikely to be able to do it
secretly exactly exactly just
think about recruiting such a number of
people so somehow you're going to have
to
find a bunch of people who are willing
to take the risk
either to their freedom or to their
pocketbook or to their reputations
uh to participate in all of this and
you're going to have to make sure that
you don't reach anybody who has
a healthy enough conscience that they
would blow the whistle on you
when it comes to um people getting
caught
attempting to do these things from
looking at the brennan center for
justice's
work on this which has looked at over a
billion votes over i don't i don't know
how many years many many years
they say that this in-person voter fraud
is not only extremely rare but there is
not even a single case in which it has
come close to actually affecting the
outcome of
of a race uh there are people who
will claim maybe cynically maybe not
that
just because this uh brennan center
gives us these numbers
it doesn't address the number of people
that are getting away with it which
simply don't show up when you hear about
oh
20 people were caught trying to do this
how can we defeat the idea that maybe
there are lots of people
not caught doing it well again
i think the you have to kind of do the
math
on it so any kind of large-scale effort
means that the difficulties go up the
costs go up
and the risk of exposure goes up the
more people are involved in this the
more votes they're involved in this
the greater the likelihood that it's
going to be found so
yeah maybe there are people who get away
with it but there are people who get
away with it
maybe affecting one or two votes you
know out of all the scrutiny that this
last election got
so far the only indictment that we've
seen for any kind of voting
irregularities was a man in pennsylvania
who voted an absentee ballot for his
mother right for donald trump
so that's the that's the typical kind of
thing that we see in these cases
most cases of vote fraud or alleged vote
fraud are not even prosecuted
because it's people making honest
mistakes right they thought that they
were registered but they weren't
or they thought that they were eligible
in this jurisdiction but they weren't or
so forth so
most of these cases have quite innocent
explanations
what would be of all of these different
mechanisms
what's the one you're most likely to get
away with
oh boy um i'm not sure that there
are that many possibilities anymore
you know back in the bad old days there
used to be a fair bit of vote fraud it
was committed both by republicans and by
democrats
um and as a result of that
you know election officials learn
through time uh what those
uh what those frauds look like um and
they
learned about how to take security
measures to make sure that those frauds
didn't occur
um and so by now with a century of
experience with
the australian ballot with the secret
ballot uh we have lots and lots of
of experience in this um and it's not
like people
have just been twiddling their thumbs
and saying oh my oh my when they
encounter problems
they've taken steps to avoid them in the
future when it comes to the us having
these 50 election systems plus dc i
guess you'd say you know it's 51
election systems
one could make the argument that um the
election
is less secure because you have so many
different systems
but on the other hand you could make the
argument that having all of these
systems actually makes it more secure
because in order to really do some kind
of fraud at
a big level you'd have to figure out a
way to manipulate
multiple different systems do you think
that having the 51 different systems
on balance makes the election more or
less secure
that's a good question i think you could
argue it both ways
certainly one could argue that if you
have separate systems
you might not have all jurisdictions
adopting best practices
and that would be an argument for a more
uniform system
on the other hand if it is a matter of
some kind of technical expertise
to manipulate these systems then having
a wide variety of systems means that
you have to have a greater variety of
technical expertise in order to do
anything significant
do you think that because of all of the
the smears that we've
heard over the last two three months
about the election of 2020
there's going to be a skepticism about
the system in some
parts uh among some communities that
will last a long time or is it as simple
as
if in 2022 politicians don't make these
claims people will generally speaking
trust the systems again
well i think that there is now a
partisan reason not to quote unquote
trust the system
whether that actually translates into
people behaving in a different way i
think is another question entirely
there are all these um concerns in
georgia for instance in the senate
runoff that
that donald trump's casting aspersions
on the fairness of the georgia election
would mean that republicans would stay
home um why
right then they definitely lose right
right why why would you do that so so um
i'm i'm skeptical that it will matter a
whole lot
what it what it does do however is to
raise the possibility of
just casting doubt on the legitimacy of
every election outcome and that's a bad
thing
yeah and that uh it seemed i mean i i
there was a woman who
confronted mitt romney in an airport a
couple of weeks ago
and almost like as a reflexive thing
she said you weren't your election
wasn't even legitimate and like who
who i didn't even know the utah 2018
election was being challenged in terms
of its legitimate
legitimacy it seems it's becoming a
catch-all for i don't like that you won
uh yeah that's right that's right um and
this has been brewing for a while it's
been a republican strategy since 2010
uh basically to elect more to erect more
and more and more barriers
um to the um to voting and
and particularly to the constituencies
that tend to vote democratic
um just in order to keep one's opponents
away from the polls
right so you know this is actually
and in that respect the 2020 election
was something of an embarrassment
uh because we had easier access to
voting than we've ever had before in our
history
and we have a whistle clean election so
now what are they going to claim
right how how can they how can they say
well actually
things do work um and so we get a
doubling down on these fraud claims
yeah and uh in fact christopher krebs uh
who worked for donald trump
said exactly that it was fine and he was
fired and so we see
the the political nature that it's
taking on uh we've been speaking
with professor john mark hansen who
teaches political science at the
university of chicago
so great having you on today i really
appreciate it it's been fun thank you